guardalo si sta guardando con gli occhi
rossi che paura ho pensato niente i
denti ormando ma e manti nissimo cosa è
successo non ci sono storie che oggi
nuovissima at the broom questa moto
cerchiamo un equipe room che ci avete
consigliato voi e cioè che il rombo del
dentista cattivo e toglierci tutti gli
eventi spiega rondi il brand di bogor la
fa più mi piace qua sotto per portarci
fortuna e per vedere altre skate lungo
se no mi seguite su instagram ancora
mettetevi comodi iniziamo subito guarda
e dice non riuscirai mai a scappare una
chiave ho preso la chiave forse si dovrà
aprire qua l'assistente dice sembra che
siamo stati bloccati dentro questa
stampa ruba la chiave a ma io l'ho già
presa la chiave dobbiamo saltare
scavalca ecco vitale che inizia mai solo
per dire facilissimo da marcare il
dentifricio e si sapete che invitava in
queste prime ore 10 mila volte andiamo
salviamo bordo ci sono due pensieri
cercare e contrattazione di contango
delle gengive
finora tutto sei buche belbo vivente
tutto fatto di dentifricio per cadere ma
se l'ho fatto è che gli spazzolini ma
vitale è rimasto a chicago sta morendo
ancora in mezzo di sentieri va bene
salvo
eccolo laggiù vedete vitale arrivato tra
il porto se ho salvato molto pericoloso
adesso cos'è questo non bisogna attento
bisogna evitare queste parti blu ok
grazie ovviamente continuate a
consigliarci le scrive il rombo e zone
commenti consigliate sere tutte oppure i
vari giochi di robot sconsigliati se
lipu regione i commenti che come quello
ora io comincio a vedere avevo un
bicchiere gigante io inizio a vedere
voli sono questi allora credo che sia
questa centrale vado prima io ok vediamo
io dico quello viola perché mi piace il
colore blu chiuso qua allora forse
questa la hall
beh un labirinto questo schifo room
aiuto che è successo c'è la lettino del
dentista spero che non si può credere in
te perché c'è un debole li aiuto aiuto
di questi bocconi disattiva ai laser
l'ho trovato il quale però non prova a
passare fini veit
abbiamo bisogno di saltare sulle
tensioni
[Musica]
io sono tranquillo 60 anziani gran
occhiata dalle dentiere che bisogna
passare in mezzo ha capito io ho detto
no a questa porta grande vediamo io che
rino degli altri spiaccicati gli spiazzi
che pure io no tutti qua ma forse ma
funziona dice piace che il pavimento è
rotto e bisogna entrare nei venti che
sarebbero questi venti nazioni questi
qua forte no forse vi sentite qua dai
sbrigati che brava si può bastare il
dottore lo detesta guarda il dentista
cattivo dobbiamo trovare un click per
nasconderci non degli hare il dentista
prova una strada trova una scatola e
mettila qua qui c'è la scatola verde
bisogna prenderla be forse si è aperta
una porta qui guarda lui prima di
addormentarsi stava guardando noi
qualche morivamo vedi per es terrore
d'acqua quindi lui in realtà ci spia ma
non si può uscire qualsiasi uno delle
scatole forse dobbiamo tornare indietro
e provare a ripassare la brava vediamo
si basi anche brava dove sistemando
perché bisogna puntare sul caso e ce
l'abbiamo fatta
[Musica]
bisogna entrare pagando il vento dove
finiremo questa volta dice che solo una
di queste porte porta porte porta a
porta alla porta giusta allora io su
questa crisi ma ho trovato questa è
praticamente di dentifricio blu bianco e
rosso sono fatta anch'io sto arrivando
vv bisogna saltare questa persona dice o
no cosa si stanno facendo un paziente
gigante nel credo proprio di sì mi
verranno a togliere tutti i denti
abbondandolo verso di lui qui non mi
dire che dobbiamo entrare dentro la sua
bocca proprio disco mettono il dottore
burmo note della secret come quello del
dottore si è mangiato gli spazzolini da
denti di prima 5 critto che siamo stati
mangiati di trovare un modo per uscire
che dobbiamo a scappare per maniere
digeribili salvo
cosa vi spiaccicato sono io per scrivere
dall'accordo ma anche tu dai ce la posso
fare
hoenig è invece di saltare gli passò
sotto il mio salviamo ma cos'è che ha
mangiato questa visione blu c'è chi ha
mangiato inter e non è un ottimale ha
insegnato la vera mela banana vento mi
ricorda qualcuno
cosa simile a quello del dottore che
rimaniamo nella spina dorsale o le cose
andiamo perché adesso si può salvare
ci sono per dire nelle salsicce pezzi
che sono notizie o no non voglio toccare
detto no no no è stata espulsa
sì questa volta non c'era nessun rumore
strano vi ricordo che vuole strano
quando siamo scappati dal produttore
forse siamo riusciti a scappare ci sono
anch'io sì questo rimando detto c'è una
casetta 4 non attira premium o queste di
nuovo e il dentista meno di a non
entrare lì dobbiamo esplorare un po la
città c'è qualcosa di contrassegno
confermato d'italia vinto il premio
winners
abbiamo già vinto capito non ci credo
allora non potete capire rapidamente non
so perché succede sempre così su rob lux
ma quando arrivi alla fine a volte se
non fai attento e clicchi tipo quel
tappetino livelli visti su un altro
gioco senza aver preso il medaglione qua
della vincita tano cadere forse bisogna
attraversare qua la città sono tutti e
fluttuanti questi città emendare io sto
facendo un giro per vedere se trovo
qualcosa e non credo di riuscire ad
arrivare in quelle altre città usuranti
quindi ok ragazza allora siccome
scappare dal primo dentista è stato
abbastanza facile velocissimo di farne
un'altra ancora un altro dentista casa
ifo guardate che cosa questo è un video
sta filmando i pazienti mentre mangiano
oppure sono impazziti non capisco ma è
un picco in candide forse o forse
artista che sta mangiando non si sta
guardando con gli occhi rossi che paura
c'è scritto questo dentista il pazzo
cerchiamo di scappare d'acqua ok non c'è
problema io da questa
quando si può entrare era per tanto
tempo che non sia morto
salviamo è simile all'altro perché anche
qua ci sono le strisce di dentifricio
barbara paziente si sa mai stato niente
i denti ormando ma e manti nissimo
guardalinee sa tutto di me che io scappo
già sappiamo ma chissà se a dobbiamo
salire soddisfazioni ne ha detto wow
bellissimo anche questo skype difficile
dell'altra
ok c'è scritto che tipo di esperimento
stanno facendo la stessa ho paura ad
entrare
che cos'è guardo ci sono romanzi cult e
c'è un apparecchio di gigante attento
rocca 34 non saltare su evidenti qualità
sta arrivando da una per ci sono dei
denti si deve saltare inglese io sono
già lì ma mi sei il figlio
dell'apparecchio e vai dentro la bocca
roulette aiuto saltiamo che paura voglio
cadere tutto c'è scritto cos'è quella
cosa dopo questo filo interdentale sarà
una bocca sono due dentisti appena ma
che succede qua
ok piano piano nel filo interdentale
questo che cos'è inversa non piace
dai dai che ce la fanno non ci credo che
è vitale mi ha superato di sull'inter
forte entrare dentro questa bocca si
ritrovino dentro che aspetto benedetti
tantissimi paura sono facendo si stanno
cercando di capire perché c'era un patto
arrivo sangue c'è scritto sa bene siamo
stati mangiati dal gigante con solo una
via d'uscita ma come con il medico
dovremo uscire
buttiamoci non manda al diavolo
ecco un altro paziente ma le cose senza
ma la picca titolo scatoloni erano
grandi una crosta che ce l'ha fatta
salviamo e ce l'ho fatta
ma bisogna andare
non capisco ok non doveva saltarlo
riprendono ok ce la posso fare bravo
vicinissimo è davvero difficile dai
potevo farci un altra persona da noi
non mi sfuggì rami all'angolo dai
possiamo farcela possiamo farcela
ok abbiamo scoperto il modo di italia
comperato un trucco per riuscire a
superare questo livello forte perché non
l'abbiamo per la speranza c'è permaloso
che tu
[Musica]
armarsi non bisogna fare tutto di fila
ma fermarsi e prendere bene le distanze
o che sono riuscite neppure a questa è
la prima cosa forse la cosa fare
dai dai dai aiuto come faccio ad
arrivare lì è difficilissimo qui anche
anch'io mi sono bloccato ci sono per ora
non ci riuscirò non ci riuscirò non ci
riuscirò mai questo livello davvero
difficilissimo minute olimpo aiuto che i
ragazzi il livello 10 del dentista è
impossibile
bravo da non lo so un'ora che proviamo a
superarlo ma non ci riusciamo per la
prima volta vitale andato più avanti e
continueremo dalla visuale di nota nei
sempre si riesce a saltare i luoghi
miracolo perché guardo per vedere dietro
mera parti nuove con tutti quegli
ostacoli sono tutti fermi a livello
dieci giorni dopo invece versino che è
veramente impossibile
proviamo mi raccomando stai attento
questo dobbiamo assolutamente sensato
n'era tanta responsabilità non è che se
sbaglio che tutti sono prenderò come
sappiamo davvero stati un ora black to
black di livello bassolino non possiamo
completare questo perché promette grande
infatti se vedete lì nella lista siamo
gli unici a livello 11 sono tutti i
fermani del 10 cioè troppo difficile
veramente che con di tale deve salutare
vediamo dove della casa dai l'ultimo
ora siamo in un posto un po dove stiamo
secondo poi juan l'altro io non devo
fare questo sbaglio sempre di racconti
perché voglio sempre bene non essere
uscito insieme a noi qui wow è vita vita
lo meritava tentate tutte doppia cosa è
successo non ho capito dove siamo dallo
stesso di a1 non è ancora finito allora
dobbiamo saltare su questa dentiera
immagino dai ormai dopo aver superato il
livello 10 che era stato il fragilissimo
potremmo fare tutto veramente in pieno
del canale riuscito a superarlo quindi
era vitale diventare bravi purtroppo
cosa sono queste bisogna andare intorno
forse bravo essi ma è finita questa
prima adesso devi saltare dai puoi
farcela
questa è una delle scarpe più difficili
che abbiamo mai fatto
abbiamo fatto forse ce l'abbiamo fatta
siamo mica ramses iscritti no ci ha
bloccato ei dove pensi di andare ai
mondiali scappiamo da qui forse c'è la
certezza non pare no wow
ok ok ok ci stiamo citiamo quale di un
vicino ai russi da forze salvato bisogna
saltare in queste cose che non sappiamo
cosa sono delle milizie sembrate no
sembrano dei denti forse la dinamo ci
siamo quasi
quello che sto giocando cabrio che si
aspetta sempre rosa perché è ok salviamo
grande eco perché i rom non finisce mai
fra unitario
dopo aver superato quelli meglio dei
superati andiamo
salendo sopra un tubo forse ora troviamo
la via d'uscita cerca subito il belgio
ci ho capito il mezzo siamo salvi era
questa la clinica del the cisco non
rientrare dentro nord andare bene perché
chiuso alla grande
purtroppo non c'è il badge ho avuto con
lui non ho mai lo trovano importanti che
siamo riusciti non mi piace solo per lo
sport del livello di essi indicare per
vedere i nostri altri di licata su
quella che preferite
buona visione
[Musica]